elle a fait un voyage depuis le japon
dans une grosse caisse en bois suspense
jusqu'au bout jusqu'à la levée du voile
tout à l'heure derrière une toile du
père de l'impressionnisme claude monet
intitulé dieppe
un paysage qui sera mise aux enchères en
juin au château d'artigny à montbazon le
temps d'économiser quelques millions
d'euros lucas chopin nous la fait
découvrir
c'est un véritable trésor qui pénètre
dans le musée des beaux-arts à tour
venus tout droit du japon dans sa caisse
en bois
cette toile de maître et la dernière
pépite dénichée par les commissaires
priseurs rouillac
c'est finalement dieppe 1 claude monet
peinte en 1882 qui est présenté à la
presse aujourd'hui claude monet a peint
ce tableau à une période très compliquée
de sa vie sa femme était morte
il était poursuivi par ses créanciers il
a 42 ans il en pleine période de doute
il a déjà fait une tentative de suicide
et il fuit il fuit il part en normandie
la rive à dieppe où il passait son temps
quand il était enfant il se sent un
enfant du pays
et là il peint ce panorama le tableau
n'a pas été exposée au public depuis
plus de 20 ans et les rouillac aimerait
qu'il reste en france
cette vente représente un grand honneur
pour le père et son fils qui n'en sont
pas à leur coup d'essai après celui que
j'ai vendu à 40 ans aymeric pour ses 40
ans vont aussi à monet c'est notre
marque de fabrique des rues yak d'avoir
des tableaux qu'ils soient anciens ou
modernes assez spectaculaire c'est une
grande joie que nous font tous ces
collectionneurs jusqu'au japon
maintenant de nous confier leurs leurs
merveilles
diab sera vendue le 6 juin prochain au
château d'artigny mise à prix 1 million
d'euros pour un tableau qui sera sans
doute a jugé bien au delà